Ernesto also feels the added pressure of
having his 16 year old twins Christian
and D'Angelo watch
he's been afraid of dogs mercy all his
life you know so I just hope that he
didn't freak out so you know I was like
whoa you know hope he doesn't you know
start crying like that I freaking out
this is what I was feeling that I have
can I share it inside yes absolutely
absolutely totally safe got it you know
you are around dogs right but I am the
pack leader so even though you are
sharing instability nobody will hurt you
okay
if you feel to stop stop go through it
go through it I will only stay there so
long you gotta gets tired of being tense
see ya okay so just go grab the fence
open the fence it's just go endless just
don't touch no talk no eye contact just
move in move in just move in don't don't
even close the door just just go
yes don't look at them just keep going
forward don't hesitate you just walk
forward this is just the same thing as
walking on fire you know
this is my own time to take away the
fear so I had a choice to keep my fear
for our home for how long I was just
taking the fear out of my life and
that's why I decided this is my time
this is the moment if I don't do it
right now I will never do it again one
step ahead and that's what I did you
ready come on let's go
well that's this is the way we want
that's very good very good energy the
pack is behaving extremely well
stop right there that's I want to show
you something about that look at that
see he's unsure so just go down please
go down there we go very good
the transformation it was okay you was
relaxed he was smiling and he kept the
dog and it was something there was
something to see yeah I was kind of
scared for him because he's been afraid
for dogs for a long time so you know
when I saw him in there it was all good